with all the revolution of the new
Colombian music and that we see everything
because there is no longer as much fear of
experimenting and doing things when with
our music
and the most beautiful thing is that it is said as
still respecting the root not for my
evolution it is revolution
[  Music]
we are ghetto that a beautiful I am
edgardo garcés producer singer
I am andrés the 2 who is with
African knowledge I also do
percussions and we are going to see good ones and Juan
Carlos Neck the chongo I am the tan
bolero and in b 0 I also feel that it is born
to unite the rhythms of the ghettos in that
aesthetic of electronic music I feel
that what has made me fall is to
find that familiarity of the
Afro-Colombian rhythms and the rhythms of Africa
and create as a single fabric and this has come out
is a general harmony  a general fabric
the drum has a lot of power and let's say
that this music was thought for the
drum in principle there were no voices
but the drum was like the front and it was
an experience  very cool
the drum is like a catalyst for
emotions and you are sad and you are
playing the people will receive that and if
you are happy or excited euphoric and the
way you play that is how the public will perceive it
is the pride that  you
fulfill that as we handle a
universal language that the drum achieves,
anyone can understand
even aliens
[Music
] we are inspired by the land the
jungle our roots
you indigenous people many things that happen
in our country Colombia has a
lot of rhythms  in our future it is
very black diverse mega diverse
lobby symbols of the universe rhythms that
obviously is of will obviously
between the pacific and the caribbean looking for
us also now and with the
tastiest most variable moods
[Music]